[Music]
thank you my name is alexander rodchenko
I'm from Moscow and I represent while
I'm not sure if I represent like several
parties in here
Caltech Institute of Science in
technology and our data science
community from Moscow I'm going to be
talking about work that we did the last
summer and presented a 3-d deep learning
workshop at nips 2016 it concerns
analyzing 3d shapes but later on we
discovered that it might be useful for
other applications as well so start from
first by this point 3d shapes can be and
3d objects can be encoded in a multiple
ways ways usually its meshes a
triangular or other kind of meshes point
clouds just some amount of points in the
frame of reference and blessed surfaces
and potentials that a more obscure
method of describing objects voxels are
quite popular and some people use
multiple projections to several
perspectives to represent a object but
that's of course not completely 3d so
first three really hard to fit into a
neural network because of their
irregular size that they have a spatial
nature which usually is wearing
processed by commercial neural networks
but they have variable size a lot of
times so it's not obvious how you put
this data inside the network and voxels
and 2d projections are yeah possible
spatial representations of objects to
put them into neural networks but for
the 2d projections there is a problem
that bodies with surfaces have bad
property of being self occluded so if
they are not transparent you cannot see
what is inside of the
volumetric bodies so it's only leaves us
with the voxels which have their
downside as well they are don't encode
sir smooth surfaces as well for example
we had a data set model net 40 it's a
benchmark in shape classification in
shape retrieval tasks and we encoded
different mesh objects into voxels with
different resolutions and you can see
they get more detailed with more
resolution that you apply but for some
objects it's quite obvious even at the
low resolution of 30 in 30 by 30 by 30
but if you have a much bigger data set
of objects it might be more difficult to
discriminate between them and also like
another kind of objects that we want to
analyze
it's biomedical imaging data for example
on the left you see MRI images of brain
with a lot of skull and other stuff cut
off and you can see it's quite sparse
and on the right we have computer
tomography images of prostate cancer
patients and you can see a lot of blue
on that on those images and blue means
lower values lower densities and if you
use some way some threshold in you can
turn most of those images into zeros so
effectively making them sparse so the
idea of using conditional neural
networks on sports data is not well not
absolutely new dr. Benjamin Graham from
yours to Warwick now he works in
Facebook research in 2015 do the
research when where he created a special
library that uses C++ and CUDA to encode
shape Nash's measures of our bodies into
a rectangular or triangular mesh three
volumetric meshes and operate on them
there is several not obvious properties
if you for example encode 3d objects in
triangular or tetrahedral mesh this
probably yeah properly called the
residual mesh it has only four different
sides adjacent to it so every
tetrahedral voxel only have four a J
other ones adjacent but cubic like cubes
like that have six-sided sides so
effectively if you have boundary around
some voxels it's much more efficient to
be in a tetrahedral space but you still
can conserve a lot of topological
properties of objects and yeah he
published this research on archives and
developed this library but there was it
was really complicated not a lot of not
really obvious how to use it besides
re-implementing other C++ or CUDA
programs on top of that but that's a
skill set that is really not that right
widespread not a lot that people can
effectively write CUDA in c++ code so we
developed pi sparse canet it started
like as a wrapper around the C++ and
CUDA library with all the Python
functionality that it needs but then we
added some additional functionality so
it would so it would be possible to
process volumetric data like biomedical
images and this is also licensed by GPL
three version three license and it's
used syphon to effectively wrap C++ and
CUDA code into Python and I'm gonna show
one more detail show you how it's done
so yeah we have some pros why we want to
do this well like the good reason is
that we want to have the efficiency of
really optimized high-performance
library that
uses the power of GPU but also we want
to have simplified interface right an
interface to get properties of
interactivity modularity debugging
essentially getting a gaming way of
looking into neural network so we could
debug and diagnose problems more
effectively also because if you use some
interchangeable format for example we
are able to train a neural network on
sparse data then translate weights of
this network to a for example Karis
model and then use for inference time
more popular engine like carrots or
something else that can encode
convolutional network and have all the
efficiency that we want in at the
insurance time but we also have some
drawbacks like this framework is
absolutely niche framework it's not
general purpose it's only reasonable to
use it when you have volumetric data
because in other cases other frameworks
work as well sometimes better and we
have a lot of optimization exactly for
this use case and the code base is
pretty complicated benjamin graham in
2015
applied his library at the data science
bowl first data center ball at Kegel
computation and one so it got a spike in
popularity but people were discouraged
because of its complexity also because
of implementation details we right now
cannot we can use special python
language loss functions and whatnot but
it requires you to translate all of the
information from GPU to CPU and that's
creates a lot of overhead which you want
to avoid if you can so let's dive into
I hope not everybody you can see the
code there size of the lair is
appropriate so on the left you can see
what is what it looks like as people a
CUDA in C++ library it's a header file
of one of the modules and it encodes
some class class of a sports network and
it has some like I'm not a huge expert
on C++ but I can understand that
we have strongly typed attributes of
this object we have some constructors
some destructor and some methods they
take other types arguments if you use
size on what you can do essentially if
you found optimized effective library
you can reimplemented our files using
siphon notation and define by DX file
and essentially essentially re-implement
well not to implement better describe
the signature of a class and signatures
of functions in siphon using this
special notation where you use CDF you
identify which classes you use and you
can only describe the parts of the
objects the only ones that you're going
to use not the complete thing like
there's a lot of methods out here but we
only need like three of those or four so
you can just describe some of them the
only ones that you need because they
only they're going to be accessible in
other sites on code and this is another
siphon file by X extension by X and we
define here an object there's going to
be an object C++ and Python object at
the same time I described them siphon
that notation here so you can see that
it's pretty similar to usual Python with
only distinctions being you add
TDF where you want to describe something
which is in a sea land or going to be
implemented underneath converted into a
sea object as well and you need a couple
of special methods in your
initialization for the size and classes
done in the following way you create an
initial initialization object C in it
and you define actually the type of
ation here is optional sighting is
absolutely completely able to use hints
and convert implicitly convert types and
so those type in here is just strictly
for optimizing the code that going to be
below so you create a seitan wrapper
object we're going to be accessible in
Python which have these attributes but
this attribute is actually a sea object
and we pass Python variables in to
constructor and we initialize new is a
special word and C++ that initializes
C++ object we assign it to this
attribute and we provide some
functionality around it because this
code in size and essentially it works in
in a sea land but it's also can be
accessed from the Python with by these
attributes oh sorry I mixed up like when
you define something as CDF it's not
accessible in Python because it's it's a
hidden sea attribute of a Python object
but if you can also define stuff here
using usual deaf or just Python just
usual Python be for example you can pass
just a plain Python code to the site
some compiler and it will guess types of
the different arguments and can convert
your Python code straight to the c code
but if you provide some additional
notation I'm going to be much up to much
optimised on a compilation step also you
need to provide explicit way to disrupt
destroy this object a lot of problems
arise when you use siphon if you have
some object for example here it's a FIFA
see object sparkle net and this object
is defined in a C code so you need
explicitly define when it's going to be
created and destroyed because if you
will it will if you not do that you're
probably going to have some segmentation
faults and memory leaks and a lot of
other memory problems so if you don't
want to touch C++ very much
you just remember two things to have
correct initialization and dialogue that
destroys most of the C objects so they
would not take more memory oh sorry yeah
so the compilation step works following
we have the original particle net module
which is essentially a bunch of CUDA
file CTP files and header files and you
can write binary write a separate file
and compile it and it will work but what
we do we added those sizin additional
files by D which mirrors the definitions
and header files that we need and define
some functionality in PI X file then
siphon and the compile time converts
those definitions and payload into CDP
file then our make file turns everything
into object files and then using Nvidia
compiler and VC C in a linker mode we
can connect and link it all together
into a so shared object which is
essentially going to be a Python module
yes so there is some new ones to that
for example if you define in a set up
dot PI file the compilation steps of all
of the
files and create a siphon extension it's
going to be linearized what I mean by
that it's gonna compile each file on its
own it would not be able to compile them
in parallel
you know like J flag for in make utility
does it so in our implementation we
decided just to compile our siphon
object separately compiled objects
object files of parse Canet in parallel
use and make for a make file and then we
relink them together on its own the
second go and we get the proper shared
object between we can use as a Python
module another interesting like problems
well not problems but an unexpected
behavior is the type assignment so if
you define for example this is the class
in the PI X sub file that describes and
sample our 3d shape object which is
described by sparse by sparse dictionary
and here for example a test we define we
define in siphon the types of those
arguments as numpy and GRA s with types
for example long and double with some
number of dimensions too so one object
is is the matrix of indices which are
not 0 and the second vector is the
features what are the values in those
nonzero voxels and what creates a sea
object we tie it to the file class in
our Python module and here for example
in the test you can see its behavior but
they're unexpected thing is the types
that siphon takes and types that numpy
assumes are different types and you've
got to be careful about that because for
example long here means standard int
but double here means NP float because
there's a some type well
mapping you've got to be careful with
that because it can create some problems
in your C functionality it's yeah it's
the second most important part of a
inter inter when you try to connect
Python to C++ is to be careful with type
conversions because it's exactly the
place where the all the data travels in
between c module python yes and size
size n can do a lot of stuff implicitly
it's really has a lot of optimized stuff
in it so for example if you return a c++
structure it can automatically detect it
and convert it to dict with keys being
attributes of the structure so what we
use the tour initially we wanted to
solve a task of shape retrieval it means
basically to use shapes to be able to
search in a library of shapes like image
search but for 3d objects and there's a
couple of nuances of that object 3d
objects can be in some classes we have a
data set that has 40 classes of
different kinds of objects planes and
whatnot which is defined by meshes
meshes that we convert to voxels and
analyze voxels so this works pretty much
like that we take mesh pass it through
the our network get a feature vector put
it in some spatial index and then we
perform retrieval on the unknown object
on a query object and we get some number
of objects that look the same so this is
a retrieval tasks and we use a special
case of metric learning how many of you
know about metric learning have you
heard about it so it's an idea that you
want to learn a representation of your
objects such that similar objects going
to be closer together in a vector space
and the more different object can be far
away and you can do this by defining a
special loss function for your deep
learning task called Cupid loss people
working in a face recognition and other
types of recognition tasks when you have
a lot of objects of different classes
usually it's better to use metric
learning setup so this is this triplet
learning trip of learning loss function
what it does it looks for positive pair
than negative pairs what it takes some
objects in the data set as the anchor
object then it finds a couple of one
negative one positive example in this
case positive means in the same class a
negative means in other classes and try
to draw the positive sample closer to
itself and the negative sample far away
from from itself it's more stable
version of other contrastive loss metric
learning like when you want to learn a
representation
you probably think like the simplest way
to do that just calculate the distance
between the same class objects and
minimize it and maximize the law
the distance between other classes yeah
it would be called contrastive loss and
in that case there might occur
situations when you in one but one batch
of optimization procedure you get some
objects close to the other but then in
the next batch it's going to draw them
far away so they can oscillate without
like optimizing the real objective
without finding the proper function that
would create a landscape on which on
that landscape similar would be close
and different would be far away by using
separate third anchor object we can
separate them in different directions
essentially creating different areas for
different classes yeah the architecture
of the network that we
just plain convolutional neural network
with maximum layers in between it has 17
layers and that you can see from this
column it's our input is 3 sparse well
if it's sparse we can process it more
efficiently for example if we render our
shape objects and in different
revolutions if we for example used dance
module something like carrots or cafe or
whatever those libraries the only
process dance matrices they have no
conception that you might not want to
process all of the zeros that occupy the
space around the object but we only have
do computations that are required we
only compute stuff around the objects
and we don't touch the zero space so
essentially our input space of this
architecture is 160 cube so we can input
any object that can be rendered in
voxels less than 168 with the with a
side of 1 161 26 26 so because we don't
care about zeros we can use different
architectures for example we can have
like 30 layers our input field would be
300 by 3 200 by 300 it will be
untrackable in a dense network but
because we have no computation of zeros
so that it might be reasonable to do
something like that and going through
this network when objects activate on
different layers they lose their spatial
sparsity and start occupying much more
channel how many of you familiar with
the like deep learning problem and deep
learning methods like we already heard a
lot of stocks on this conference about
that so you can think about this it
tries to convert spatial dimensions into
a semantic channel dimensions which
represent separate features and for
example we will those spatial
dimensions up to the last layer but our
channel dimensions would be 192 an hour
sparsity is a hundred percent so it
means that we have completely dense
information so we started from 0.18
percent sparse data for the shapes and
for example MRI data set of brains it
has mean sparsity of 10%
so it means 90% of voxels in the brain
images are zeros so we don't care about
them but when it goes through the
network all of the zeros get compressed
and all the only the semantic
information remains and complexity time
complexity doesn't grow as a cube of
input resolution but grows on the
linearly or logarithmically because it
only takes yeah information that a
sparse image has so you can see for
example in this plot that we had a shape
of a car we had the mesh object that
represented a shape of a car it goes
through the network it some convolutions
after four minutes
then it goes through the pooling layer
resolution gets smaller it's now 60 and
in 3-year layers it was a half of
dimension half of its resolution size so
it was 126 now 61 or 62 and we go
through the layers until we get just one
dimensional vector which represents a
feature vector of this of that object so
we evaluated that on some data set
compared it to the other architectures
and methods that people use this network
for example is dense one and it's only
uses 30 by 30 by 30 as input resolution
this network uses multiple projections
of 3d objects and concatenate them and
passes them through several copies of
neural
network then assembles feature vectors
together and uses them with descriptions
in this network which is uses multiple
views as their presentation pretty good
actually advertorial tasks because a lot
of objects have one projection side
where you can have such a projection
that would discriminate between classes
very effectively but we are pretty
similar our performance is comparable to
the performance of state-of-the-art
methods and we are much more
computationally efficient because we
don't do any computation that we don't
don't need to and we utilize good
effectively so yeah you can see like on
this piece in II plot this is we have
192 feature vectors to represent 3d
objects then we using Tiffany will
project them to this to 2d space and you
can see some similarity between objects
for example here's our like big storage
boxes or closets or here we have doors
and wardrobe wardrobes something and
here we have bathtubs and bathtubs and
sinks so it's it finds common common
elements and a 3d shape representation
yeah we got some conclusions from that
shape data sets are really because of
the because of their small number of
classes they don't really need big
resolution more if you have more voxels
you maybe need to get a deeper network
so the information from the different
scale would be integrated better and our
networks actually better to use them on
something that has internal structure
something that has uneven internal
structure like medical imaging data
which I showed previous them because
for example when you encode and shape a
mesh into a voxel form
it doesn't really care what is inside of
that it's actually works only on a
surface of the object so why are we
spending all of this computational power
to process something that is not really
affecting the discrimination or
representation so it might be more
efficient efficient for dense well not
dance sparse data which has internal
structure like organs or brains yes and
I wanted also to share like an idea that
we had when we trained all this stuff
because we didn't used a lot of cool
frameworks that are exist now we had to
implement our own hyper obtain a hyper
parameter optimization scheme so what we
did we used Google spreadsheet API and
we wrapped it in a panda's object so we
were able to run several workers and
which worker used Google spreadsheet as
as the common object to store the
information about experiments so here
for example on the left side we defined
all the hyper parameters they owned on
the right side it constantly updated our
metrics when they are were computers and
using this column for example we just
wrote we wrote that if we want to stop
it we just wrote stop and when the
network when the worker taken this
information from the Google spreadsheet
it stopped or not so it was a easy and
cheap way to use Google spreadsheet
either as the coordination server and
also like well not exactly a dashboard
but to collect information about the
experiments so that was pretty
interesting as well so yeah special
thanks to a couple of people who
contributed some stuff to the repository
it's because it's pretty complicated we
really require a lot of help with
experts in C++ and CUDA and if you
every time we would be really glad if
you can give us a hand and also I wanted
to say hi from Moscow data science
community lights code open data science
we have a lot of people and it's
probably one of the reasons why Russians
win a kegel competition so much because
we have some resources only in Russian
that uh where people share information
about their approaches architectures
ideas and whatnot so I don't know how
keggle policy works with that but um
that's what it is and we have a lot of
expertise and all kinds of stuff and I
hope when we going to have our first PI
data by data event in Moscow some of you
might join us that would be pretty great
thank you how much for time for Q&A and
maybe five minutes
five minutes okay yeah it was our
samples are different measures of
different objects there were 40 classes
and approximately 12,000 samples and
they were like not really so much
diverse but if you need if you have much
more classes you're probably going to
get more benefit from bigger resolutions
so that's what are some of our fun
findings we needed to reduce the spatial
resolution of the samples but you can
only reduce it using conversional or
pulling layers and you need to stack
them together so the information flow
would be like well exchange of
information from spatial than dimension
to the feature dimensions would be equal
on each step you cannot just drop in one
layer all of the dimensions so it
probably wouldn't work yeah
oh really
but shape is this shape encoded as a 2d
images or 3d images metric learning yeah
absolutely
metric learning can be applied to any
setup if you have a concept of closeness
relationship of similarity and
distinction you can use metric learning
but now they're even better approaches
to do metric learning for example
histogram roll loss or central loss so
there's a lot of new developments in
that field in recent time we can talk
about it later
any question
well you can do that but it's not really
required if we have a pre-processing
step of rotating in distorting samples
to achieve invariance to those factors
so if they are misaligned it's not
really a problem because the its it
tries to learn concepts that are
underneath the voxels so if the line is
you know a little bit jewelry because it
goes diagonally and if the line is
straight it's the network will equate
those probably it's not probably going
to make a lot of difference yes what
well only if you only if you train it
without using those kind of data
augmentation but for example if you have
standard sized position of things you
can use it without rotation for example
brain images a lot of times are centered
appropriately so you can use this
information without rotations because
every new sample of brain image probably
going to be centered and aligned
properly yes they'll oh that's
interesting there might be a connection
actually but uh no no those these
convolutions are works the same as they
would be in a dance setup but they are
all of the activations going through the
network they they not represented as
square or cubic grid they only
represented as the dictionaries and CUDA
kernels what they doing they operating
on a sparse dictionary representation of
activation
yes it's free old school but the
Benjamin Graham actually implemented
several different kinds of pooling
layers he has different variants for
example he invented fractional pooling
and some people described it to be very
advantageous in some setups oh yeah of
course
no if you have structured input it's
probably going to learn the structures
of it I probably got it I'm yeah well
I'm not sure maybe uh well we losing
like smooth information but because we
have bodies with volume inside of it if
we provide not just for those meshes
they only have zeros and ones ones were
occupation of this voxel and 0 was non
occupation but for biomedical image in
the voxel we have information about
density so if the information in those
nonzero voxels represents some shape
it's going to learn it yeah we finished
yeah really oh it's let's answer another
one yeah really changing but I don't
want you don't know what is it how do
you say synchronization that seems like
in image recognition basis they change
images with some different kind of
transformations to make sample bigger
and yea augmentation we can do this
augmentation as well by adding some
random noise in the other side or
changing flipping the some voxels at
some places for example actually there
are some interesting connections we
right now also experimenting with using
higher wavelengths to turn turn 3d
images into sparse representation in a
wavelet wavelet space and then process
them so there exists some interesting
wavelet transformation that can turn
smooth objects into sparse and if they
are equal have enough equivalent
information we can learn the same
properties but your question was with
the same way just a just a tender you
just calculate the mean and subtract it
if you want yeah well it's a dictionary
it's only nonzero elements so any
operation on nonzero elements would be
the equivalent like input objects a
normalized object no it's just only
color would change right I mean like
color represents the value in this voxel
so if we normalize stuff it just changed
the color yes
oh yeah of course I mean we had tested
we went found what would be the input
what would be the input image maximizing
different outputs of different vectors
and the science found out that sometimes
look a little bit like 3d harmonic
functions you know like you know when
people look at the filters extracted
from the network they sometimes look
like Gabor filters or edge filters or
Kanak all kinds of filters so yeah we
found similar stuff like zero harmonics
harmonics with some special numbers like
two things close to each other it looks
similar but they are you know a little
bit distorted tilted to suit the data
set better goggle when they have the
videos of your heart yeah you need to
predict the cancer and I think the
beginning team use RNN reads
convolutional neural networks and r9 for
this time kind of thing and is it like
the same as you are doing but it is
slightly different way or is it like a
completely different well it's probably
completely different because you can
turn 4d you can understand this module
it doesn't work only on 2d or 3d it
works on and spatial dimensions and M
feature dimensions so when you represent
your information in n dimensional form
it doesn't really matter the only
difference is that your spatial
dimensions would be all processed by
conclusions but your feature
transformation would be multiplied by
weight matrices like like they usually
do so you can put in five dimensional
information but it doesn't probably not
going to make a lot of sense
because we don't have 5d imaging or
anything there also was a experiments
with the activity recognition when
people try to they had short snippets of
videos and they turned 2d video with
time
and they rolled it out as a 3d tender
and they used that to training and
essentially one of the excesses was time
and it worked yeah it did some good
numbers but I haven't recreated that
experiment yet but it's not the best way
to do that yeah but the only constraint
you've got to have sparse representation
of your spatial data thank you
[Applause]
[Music]